- What do we got here?
Well, we get a couple of what
I refer to as the neo-classics.
The one on the left
is a Mercury Cougar.
OK.
But the one on the right--
no, you know what?
I think that's a Spartan.
Why am I sitting here looking?
We should just go
in there and look.
Yeah, let's see.
Let's see, man.
Oh, they got a
Corvette right there too.
And it's an '82
Pepto-Bismol pink.
[laughing]
If you're sick to your
stomach and you look at this,
it only makes you sicker.
- Right.
So that's not good.
You might throw
up in your mouth.
These I find
bizarrely interesting.
And that one's got
T-tops on it too.
That little blue
one's kinda cool, man.
Classic Tiffany.
OK, that's a Tiffany.
I want to see if anybody's home
before I make anybody nervous.
Where's the front
door in this place?
Is it through the gates?
- I think so.
Here we go.
- Maybe there's a bell--
- Maybe.
[knocking]
Well, you know, if I
start looking at the cars,
I bet you they'll come out.
Excuse me, but, uh, could
you read this word for me
here on the grill?
- Could I?
- Yes.
Ha-ha.
Spartan.
Thank you.
You were right on the money.
With the T-tops, it could
be a Mustang or a Cougar,
'cause Cougar did
do T-tops as well.
But it's probably
a Mustang, right?
Hi.
Is this your house?
Well, darling,
then this is perfect.
I'm Danny.
Oh, that's fantastic.
All right, all right.
- I'm Kevin.
This is Kevin.
What's your name?
Monique Brewster, it's
indeed a pleasure to meet you.
Right back at you.
I hope you don't mind,
we're car people.
What in the world are you doing
with a Tiffany and a Spartan?
Well, you got good taste.
Nice.
All right.
You speak it like I speak it.
It's their face.
They're gorgeous.
Neo-classics like the
Spartan and Tiffany are cool.
Some consider them
gaudy and inauthentic,
and I can appreciate that
side of the discussion.
But Spartan cars were the
brainchild of auto designer Ron
Sparks, who built these cars
in San Marcos, California
in the 1980s and the '90s.
Now, the 1920s-style
bodies are made
from aluminum and fiberglass,
and they sit on top
of a Datsun 280Z chassis.
Now, the Tiffanys, they were
built around the Mercury
Cougars by the Classic Motor
Carriage Company in Miami,
which is one of the biggest kit
car manufacturers in the world.
Some take issue with calling
these Frankencars kit cars,
because unlike
those do it yourself
models, neo-classics like
the Tiffany and Spartan
were assembled in factories.
So call them whatever
you like, these
are unique rides
that will no doubt
have heads turning and
scratching wherever they go.
How long have you had them?
I've had this
one for about six
and this one for about eight.
- All right.
You know there's
only 500 of these--
Of the Spartans.
--made in the
whole wide world.
See, I called that.
I'm like, that's a Spartan.
He did call it.
Then there was only
1,500 of these made.
Of the Tiffanys, yeah.
And when was the last
time either one of them
were on the road?
I just drove this one
maybe about an hour ago.
Oh, really?
[laughing]
That one's up and
running and driving.
- And this one runs too.
- OK.
I got you.
That's all good stuff.
I love them both, but these
Spartans are really cool.
What year is it?
- '86.
The 280Z is what they
built them off of.
That's where the
T-tops came from.
There you go.
I'm just curious, would
you ever sell this car?
Someone came around and asked
me, and I was really like, no.
But I'm kind of--
- Thinking about it?
--in the wings of that.
So as far as just
getting information
and keeping that in mind.
- I got you.
We can talk, right?
Yes, absolutely.
Well, let me do this.
Let me trade some info with you.
- OK, awesome.
You think about it.
And we'll talk again.
- OK.
- Thank you.
- Awesome, god bless.
Thank you for taking the time
and talking about your cars.
Thank you very much.
Very nice to meet you.
Absolutely.